this is the akpati's biggest rally of
its election campaign here in Istanbul
more than 30 years ago ER Duran was
first elected mayor of the city a job
that would shape his political career
today he's defending his legacy accusing
his Challenger Kamal kalistarolu of
dividing the nation and resorting to
slurs and accusations to attack him
bye-bye come on Mr Kamal drink as much
as you want you can drink a full keg but
even that will not make you better my
nation will not give the floor to an
alcoholic a drunkard
erdoran has been the driving force
behind 10 major election wins for the
governing agbati since he became its
leader in 2003.
but presidential and parliamentary
elections due May the 14th are proving a
major test for both
president president
of the decade
personal and political Freedom will
continue
under their leadership now is the time
for change
supporters dismiss accusations the party
has undermined turkey's democracy as
well as its traditionally secular
society by favoring Islamic institutions
everyone is free here I'm free my child
is free people make their own choices
being availed or unveiled woman it
doesn't matter
others praise major infrastructure
projects carried out across the country
with the many huge projects underway the
economy will boom and the country will
remain stable after the election is over
The Arc party says it's reforming its
institutions and giving new candidates a
chance to flourish
I'm one of the new
fake trying to
act and react here in Turkish policies
for the coming five years so with me
together there are many many new faces
and the change will come with its new
faces under the leadership
in a matter of weeks erdoran inaugurated
turkey's first nuclear plant a gas field
in the Black Sea and the largest
domestically built warship such acts
show a man true to his words say his
supporters but for his opponents there
could be a sign of how desperate he is
to win hearts and Minds Istanbul
but a New York Jury has found that
former U.S